[Musique]
mélanie poquet que l'on retrouve en
plateau bonsoir ça tout autre sujet le
retour de votre coup de coeur culture
une histoire dont vous allez nous parler
et mireille la planche à 16 ans depuis
trois ans sur facebook elle est élue
boudin d'or de son lycée titre insultant
qu'elle a choisi de porter mais un jour
elle est seulement boudin de bronze le
point de départ d'une pièce les petites
reines présenté au prix ce modèle en
cours
au départ c'est même un ouvrage de
clémentine bové qui est sorti en 2015
prix lire du meilleur roman jeunesse de
cette même année le prix nouvelle revue
pédagogique et le prix 1000 pages
alors on y suit donc mireille mais aussi
hakima et astrid
les deux jeunes filles qui la devance
dans ce concours du boudin de l'année
une rencontre qui mène à un projet
inédit est présente le 14 juillet l'agad
la garden party de l'elysée regardez un
extrait de la bande annonce et parents
sont d'accord pour te les séries comme
ça à 12 ans sur les routes de prendre
converser les forêts les montagnes jours
5 nuits et des jours ça va se faire
[Musique]
c'est comme un pavage de signer un fer
la pétanque c'est bien d'avoir embauché
waouh c'est parce que passé mais d'un
coup de vent ça fait très longtemps une
maturité surprenante votre âge pourquoi
il y avait les allures et c'est une
pièce qui parle d'un sujet qui fait
souvent l'actualité depuis ces dernières
années c'est le harcèlement sur internet
et oui du postulat de départ à un
concours méchant un titre dégradant des
boudins d'or d'argent et de bronze
les trois filles en font une force la
metteur en scène juliette henman
s'inspire du film little miss sunshine
et choisit aussi de parler de
l'exclusion de quoi et on exclut
pourquoi et surtout par qui un sujet
lourd dans une pièce touchante
un spectacle qui peut parler à tout le
monde pour sensibiliser merci mélanie
les téléspectateurs qui vous retrouve
tout à l'heure dans votre émission 7,8
culture